um it says breaking texas dps now say
there was no school police officer who
encountered or engaged the mass
uh shooter at rob elementary school the
shooter was not confronted before entry
and it appears he walked into the school
through an unlocked door
we got to lock the doors
that seems obvious to everyone involved
the doors of the school have to be
locked you know i showed up at my old
school i was with a friend this was
years ago and i was you know i thought
i'd do like a little homecoming like hey
this is where i went to school i thought
i could walk down i had no idea and this
was years ago i had no idea how like how
shut down these schools were it was all
locked i knocked on the door they were
like hello excuse me
and through the glass i was like yeah i
went to school here i'm tim dylan yeah i
was on joe rogan we talked about bill
gates
and
they
they looked at me like the guy looked at
me like i was crazy showing up at a
school and now you know upon
further reflection i now i get it it
does seem crazy do you think uh though
cause the glock door is inevitably
someone will get in you think at some
point what we need to do is have decoy
schools like saddam hussein palaces very
interesting the students are in a decoy
school right and then we have doubles in
the other schools right but it's going
to get out which school is which well
then you got to check you got to keep
moving like what about if we educated
kids underground underground would be
like underground we have underground
cities we have underground military
bonkers right the kids don't need
sunlight
they can certainly underground we can
recreate the conditions of uv light or
the military industrial complex will
make a clip out of this yeah everyone
arm up and don't leave
and just let delivery people deal with
it yes delivery people are the only
brave ones now yeah i mean i was talking
about that today somebody on instacart
delivered me two candles they had to
take that long walk
from the door to the wall to their car
in the walgreens parking lot depending
on the time of day in los angeles that
ain't nothing that's nothing you have no
idea what could happen on your way i
guarantee you an instacart or postmates
worker on the way to the car has met
their end yeah or release a new virus
for our own safety to get us back
indoors you just see a burrito fall to
the floor and then blood yeah because
that people that leave their houses now
really are the the most brave yeah and
it's gonna be it's the most brave
they're the most brave people they're
they're outside teachers maybe are more
brave than cops now i mean teachers
teaching might be a more deadly job than
police gotta arm them yeah you gotta arm
these kindergarten teams well here's the
deal in texas why didn't they have guns
i'm not even kidding like why did they
not have guns in texas like is this all
the gunman's fault or can we lay a
little bit of blame on the teachers who
weren't carrying these [ __ ] moving from
california that's what it is you have a
bunch of liberal teachers moving from
california that don't have guns and
aren't focused on the defense of the
school and it's not just enough to have
guns again i i just want to focus right
we need body armor because the other guy
and that is what's being seriously
suggested yeah well you need body armor
because the guy's going to come if he's
got a bigger gun he's prepared he's good
i watch a lot of self-defense videos
right the perp always has the advantage
right because he's the one that comes in
and goes we're doing this right you have
to go oh [ __ ] we're doing this because
you he he has the element of surprise
the element is surprised and he may have
an ar-15 those things are pretty
efficient they do their job so what we
need is what let's let's plan this out
we one student we need one teacher at
the chalkboard
handgun maybe
ready in the one hand then we need
another teacher so you're saying just a
teacher
pretty much all day
at the at the at the ready well you
don't know if the kid's got a gun so you
got to have one
facing the kids that's right and then
you have to have someone watching your
blind spot so we need another teacher a
teacher's eight if you will we teach his
age they don't even need to keep his
door we just need two armed people in
each classroom one watching the door one
watching the windows ar-15s drawn
it's not a bad idea you have two we have
two people in the classroom they each
have an ar-15 out yeah and they really
and it's just got a fun way to quiet the
kids down too yeah quiet down
it's nap time yeah yeah now the kids
themselves may be armed because it's
their right yes
but
as long as you have an ar-15 you have
the advantage because their little hands
can't quite grasp or deal with the
pushback of an ar-15 yeah you can take a
few of them out if you need to
because now we're fine we need to live
in the last scene of a quentin tarantino
movie where everyone's pointing guns at
each other at all times we're finding
the common ground here and this is what
i want to stress so if you have a few
people in each classroom with ar-15s one
trained on the kids one on the door of
the classroom and one on the teacher
because you don't know what they're
going through oh it's a great point yeah
because the teacher might flip out so
you need you need one kid marshall yes
in the class kid marshall with a gun
who has a gun on the teacher
you need two teacher's aides
with ar-15s one at the door one at the
class yes
yes interesting yes it's not a bad idea
and you need school uniforms and those
uniforms are body armor
kevlar body armor uniform yes
ar15 at the kids ar15 at the teacher
ar15 at the door
problem solved not a big deal not a
tough way to live at all it's fine it's
totally comfortable and the most
important part reasonable right right
and people in other countries would
watch this and they would they would
think it's comedy but what it actually
is is a good plan it's a great smart
thought-out cogent plan it's not a bad
idea not at all yeah otherwise we're
going to be
just relying on what we're relying on
now which i guess is chance happenstance
luck yeah
yeah because now it seems like a casino
a little bit if you send your kids to
school yeah no a little bit of a casino
even in supermarkets i would feel a lot
safer yes armed i would feel a lot safer
if the army was there while i got
lettuce
if the if the military could potentially
enforce a barrier around the supermarket
and check people as they went in yeah
we need military checkpoints at safeway
i don't think it's a bad idea i don't
think so
military outside supermarkets i don't
think so at all